>>> AMERICA HAS A NEW OBSESSION.
AND HER NAME IS MEGAN BE,
DESIGNED TO BE A LITTLE GIRL'S
BEST FRIEND.
>> DON'T WORRY, KATIE.
EVERYTHING IS GOING TO BE OKAY.
DO YOU WANT TO DANCE WITH ME?
>> AND PROTECT HER AT MY ANY
COST.
>> I WON'T LET ANYTHING HARM
YOU.
>> MEGAN IS A BOX OFFICE POWER
HOUSE, BUT SHE HAS CAPTIVATED
ONE DEMOGRAPHIC ABOVE ALL, GAY
MEN.
MEGAN IS THE DEFINITION OF GAY.
MEGAN'S PLASTIC POST IS ON MY
NECK.
WE'RE SLAPPING TOGETHER A
SEQUEL, WHICH PROMISES TO BE
EVEN MORE GAY.
>> I'M MEGAN.
I'M YOUR BEST FRIEND, YOU DUMB
BITCH.
>> IT'S MEGAN, 2.0.
STRAP IN TO.
>> GO MEGAN.
>> I SIGNED UP FOR A
SHANIA TWAIN SPIN CLASS.
I SHOULD GO HOME.
>> IT'S LIKE ROSE, BUT FOR GAYS.
WANT A DANCE YOU CAN DO ON
TIKTOK?
WELL, GAG ON THIS.
>> WHOO!
>> LITERALLY GIVING ME LIFE.
>> I HAD TO TURN OUT FOR MY LIL
HOMO.
BUT SERIOUSLY, YOU GUYS ARE LIL
HOMOS.
>> SEE, YOU CAN SAY IT.
>> IF THERE'S ONE THING GAY MEN
LOVE, IT'S UNHINGED PLASTIC
WOMEN.
>> I'M BORED.
DRIVE ME HOME.
>> MEGAN, YOU MESSY HO, I'M SOB
SESED WITH YOU.
>> EVERYONE STOP.
GET AWAY FROM HER.
SHE'S NOT YOUR FRIEND.
SHE'S A KILLER, AND SHE WILL
KILL YOU.
>> OH, MY GOD.
ARE YOU FROM THE SHOW GIRLS?
>> YEAH.
>> OH, YEAH, YOU HAD YOUR BUTT
EATEN.
THAT'S SO COOL.
>> IT IS?
>> YES.
JOIN US!
>> REALLY?
EVEN THOUGH I'M STRAIGHT.
>> MAMA IF YOU'RE GETTING YOUR
ASS ATE ON TV YOU'RE AN ALLY,
SIS.
PLAY SOME MUSIC
♪ NOTHING TO LOSE ♪
>> NO, MEGAN, REAL MUSIC.
>> OKAY, YOU HUNGRY SLUTS.
>> MEGAN 2.0.
THIS ONE'S FOR THE GAYS.